ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครู Arty
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียเย้กลับมาเจอกับครัวตี้
ครูพี่เอ๋ในช่องคอม frenzel ไทยนะครับ
ตำบลนะให้อยู่ด้านบ่กินข้าว
กู Artist ขาวันนี้ผมวันอะไรคะวันนี้ใช่
ไหมวันนี้วันอะไรวันนี้วันพุธครับวันพุธ
นะคะได้ครับวันนี้วันพุธหน้าวันพุธวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะที่ 29 แล้วครับวันนี้ 29 แล้ว
ไม่ใช่ครับเดือนอะไรคะเดือนนี้ยังเป็น
เดือนมิถุนายนครับเดือนมิถุนายนนี้คศอะไร
คะคศ 2000  22 ครับ
ปีคศอะไรคะปีพตใจมั้ย 2000
ที่
565 ครับมัน 560 หาครูเอ๋เอ๋น่าจะง่วง
นอนแล้วเนี่ย
เออแล้วเวลาตอนนี้เวลา
เวลาตอนนี้หรอ 3
21:20 นน
9:00 นนาที
อาจาร์ยกับผู้เอกก็เลยง่วงนอนไง 19:00
และห้องนอนใช่ไหมแต่ครู Arty ดูไม่ง่วง
เลยนะ
รู้
อะไรนะสวัสดีรู้ว่าเวลาเจอกับกูเองเนี่ย
จะได้ไปเที่ยวไงจะได้ดิบเดียวเขาก็ได้ไป
เที่ยวก็ยังไม่ง่วง
เราสองคนชอบไปเที่ยวออนไลน์ได้ครับวันนี้
วันนี้จะพานักเรียนไปเที่ยวที่ไหนกันครับ
วันนี้สำหรับคลิปนี้คุณพานักเรียนไปภาค
ใต้
ภาคใต้
ดู
คลิปกันๆเราก็พาไปภาคใต้หรอไปข้างใต้ไป
เสน่หาทะเลไปว่างนางทะเลใช่ครับไปอาบแดด
กู Arty ชอบอาบแดดไหมคะอ้าไม่ชอบครับแดด
ร้อนหวัดดีคิดว่าคนไทยส่วนใหญ่ก็ไม่ข้อ
เอาแบบเฮ้ยแต่นักเรียนน่ะชอบเนาะมีอะไรนะ
มีอะกันแดดคือแดดแล้วนะคะทาแล้วก็นอนแล้ว
ก็ร้อนแบบอาบแดดนะคะไทยคนไทยไม่ชอบคนไทย
กลัวกลัวร้อนถึงไม่ชอบเราอยู่ร้อนก็เลย
กลัวร้อนๆนะนักเรียนอยู่ไหนอยู่ประเทศ
หนาวเพราะชอบร้อนๆนะคะอ่าเดี๋ยวพาไปดูค่ะ
คุณอาจไปไหนกันครับวันนี้
อยากไปทะเลใช่ไหมไปทะเลที่
เห็นไหมคะเห็นแล้วครับมีแผนที่ประเทศไทย
ออกเป็นแผนที่ภาคใต้ของประเทศไทยใช่ไหม
ครับเนี่ยแผนที่พักใต้ของประเสริฐไปให้
ครูเอ๋หาอะไรรู้ไหมหาอะไรครับเพราะๆปากกา
เข้
วันนี้เราจะไปเที่ยวจังหวัดพังงากระผม
จังหวัดพังงาเดี๋ยวนะพังงาอยู่ตรงไหนกลัว
ที่หาก่อนอ้อครัวตีเจอแล้วนักเรียนเจอรึ
ยังอยู่ก็คือเจอยังเจอเลยนะแล้วพังงานาย
อยู่ใกล้ๆกับภูเก็ต
คือนักเรียนบอกโอ้ครูแผนที่อันเนี้ยเข้า
ใจเพราะว่าภาษาอังกฤษ
เขาจะโอเคกูอาชีพทำงานอยู่ตรงไหนคะถ้าภาค
ง่ายอยู่อ่าติดอยู่ใกล้ๆกับเกาะภูเก็ต
ครับเกาะภูเก็ตจะเป็นเกาะอยู่ด้านซ้ายมือ
ของรูปนี้กูเองว่าภูเก็ตเสียงนี้หวยวงวง
เกาะภูเก็ต 5 นี่ไงภูเก็ตข้างบนภูเก็ตก็
จะเป็นพังงาหน้ากูเองให้เป็นสีเขียว
5 อยู่ตรงนี้ครับเพราะฉะนั้นพังงาก็จะ
ติดทะเลใช่มั้ยใช่ติดทะเลแล้วมีทะเลเยอะ
อ่าตี้ว้าวทั้งงานเนี่ยจะมีมีทะเลช่วงตรง
นี้นะคะตรงนี้น่ะเรียกว่าอ้าวพังงา
แล้วก็มีแค่เลด้านนี้เลยว่าทะเลอันดามัน
ครับ 2 ด้านมีทะเล 2  2 ด้านของจังหวัด
พังงางานเลยและเอาพังงาก็อยู่ในทะเลที่
เรียกว่าทะเลอันดามันนะคะอ่ะหูฟังนี้ก็
เป็นอ่าวไทยแล้วก็อ้าอะไร
ที่นี้แหละเราไปพังงาเนี่ยอ่ะจริงๆวันนี้
ครูเอ๋อยากจะพานักเรียนไปเที่ยวแถวนี้เลย
ค่ะหมู่เกาะสุรินทร์หมู่เกาะสิมิลัน
ไม่รู้เราจะพูดได้ถึงไหนแล้วก็อ่าวพังงา
นะคะถามพังงานะโอเค
เดี๋ยวที่ลากเราไปเอาไหนกันก่อนครับไปหมู
ก่อนไหนกันก่อนที่แรกนะคะเราไปล้งผ่าน
พังงากันก่อนดีกว่าค่ะโอเคไปนี่บริเวณ
หนึ่งที่ครู Arty ต้องรู้จักแน่นอนที่ไหน
ครับเขาล่ะอ๋ออ๋อเขาหลักนะคะเขาล่ะเขา
หลักตรงนี้เป็นศาลเจ้าพ่อเขาหลักเขาหลัก
เป็นภูเขาเนาะควรที่ครับเป็นภูเขาควรที่
เคยไปงอกเป็นภูเขาแล้วก็คือ
น้ำหนักนี้แล้วนักเรียนก็สีแดงดีกว่า
ข่าวที่อยู่ติดทะเลจ้าได้ง่ายติดทะเลเรา
ก็เป็นภูเขาแบบนี้นัดสารเนี่ยค่ะนักเรียน
จะอยู่ตรงนี้
ตรงนี้เป็นถนนณตรงนี้ก็เบื่อลงมาแล้วก็
ทะเลเนาะครับทรายเมื่อก่อนดูแล้วนะกลัว
นิดหน่อยนะสมัยก่อนนะเพราะว่าเป็นหน้าผาๆ
นั้นเป็นหน้าผาสูงนะคะแล้วก็มีทะเลด้าน
หน้าเขาหลักจะสวยๆเนี่ย
ตอนนี้มีโรงแรมมีรีสอร์ทนะคะเยอะนี่เขา
ล่ะข้างหน้าเขาหลักราคาก็เป็นที่ท่อง
เที่ยวที่หนึ่งแต่ตรงนี้ก็ต้องบอกนัก
เรียนก่อนนะคะว่ามีสีนามินะคะ
2010  2004
ก็
สวัสดีทำไม่ได้และนานมากแล้วตอนนั้นครัว
ติ้งเป็นเด็กอยู่เลยตอนที่มีสินามิหา
ขา
เป็นเด็กอยู่ตอนนั้นอายุ 20-50
คือสวยคนไทยก็เลยบอกว่าทะเลแถวๆข้างหน้า
เขาหลักเนี่ยเป็นทะเลของเจ้าพ่อเขาล่ะ
ถ้าจะลงไปเล่นก็ต้องไหว้เจ้าพ่อก่อนนะคะ
ก็เป็นที่หนึ่งที่แนะนำแต่ว่าแนะนำนิด
หน่อยเพราะว่าเราจะไปที่อื่นแล้วก็มีอัน
นึงก็เป็นประเพณีของจังหวัดพังงาก็คือการ
ปล่อยเต่า
หือว้าวมีเต่าทะเลใช่ไหมครับใช่อันนี้น่า
จะเต่าสนุกนะฮะแล้วก็มีการปล่อยเต่าลง
ทะเลนะคะ
แถวๆตะกั่วพี่ปลาเขาหลักเท่านั้นล่ะค่ะ
ขับโอเคทีนี้เราจะไปกันนะที่เราจะไป
เที่ยวกันไปที่ไหนกันต่อครับที่เราบอก
แล้วว่าเราจะไปที่หมู่เกาะสุรินทร์เกาะ
สุรินทร์โอเคสุรินทร์นะคะอุ้ยเอกอ้านี่
เลยหมู่เกาะสุรินทร์เคยได้ยินชื่อไหมคะ
เคยได้ยินครับหมู่เกาะสุรินทร์ไม่ใช่
จังหวัดสุรินทร์นะคะอ้าไม่ใช่จังหวัด
สุรินทร์อยู่ภาคอีสานและหมู่เกาะอันเนี้ย
ชื่อเหมือนกันกับจังหวัดสุรินทร์แต่ไม่
ใช่จังหวัดสุรินทร์อยู่จังหวัดพังงานาย
จังหวัดพังงาหมู่เกาะสุรินทร์หมู่เกาะ
สุรินทร์มีเกาะใหญ่ๆกี่เกาะครับครูอตี้บท
ที่เห็นในรูปคู่กับตัวที่เห็นมีเกาะอยู่ 2
เกาะครับเกาะใหญ่นะอ้าก็ใหญ่ๆมีสองเกาะ
ที่นั้นเนี่ยหมู่เกาะสุรินทร์จะมี 2 เกาะ
มีเกาะสุรินทร์ 1 กับซึ่งอานาโกตี้กับ
สุรินทร์ใต้ครับ
กู Arty เคยไปหมู่เกาะสุรินทร์ไหมขวดอี
ไม่เคยไปหมู่เกาะสุรินทร์ค่ะไม่เคยไปแล้ว
นะตายกับอย่างไม่เคยไป
เดี๋ยววันนี้กูเอกจะผ่านผัวที่ไปอ่ะก็ดี
ครับดีครับจะได้รู้ว่ามีอะไรที่หมู่เกาะ
สุรินทร์บ้าง
ที่หมู่เกาะสุรินทร์นะคะมีสุรินทร์เหนือ
กับสุรินทร์ใต้เวลาเท่าไปเราต้องนั่งเรือ
เนาะ
ใส่ครับเพราะว่าเป็นเกาะใช่ไหม
เป็นขอเราก็ต้องนั่งเรือไปสิ
ขับรถไปไม่ได้นะคะ
นักเรียนครูเป็นอะไรเวลาไปน่ะเขาก็จะเอา
เรือเข้าไปจอดตรงนี้อ๋ออ๋อขับเข้าไปข้าง
ในนะเลยว้าวก็เราเรียกตัวเองว่า
อ้าวแม่ยายอ๋ออ๋อเข้าไปที่ค่าแล้วเมื่อ
เช้าแม่ยายมีอะไรครับทำไมต้องไปที่อ่าว
แม่ยายเกาะน
อ้าวแม่ยายตรงนี้จะมีชายหาดค่ะตรงนี้ชาย
หาดเพราะตรงไม่มีอุทยานแห่งชาติอ่าเป็น
เป็นออฟฟิศ
เป็นอะไรนะเป็นออฟฟิศของ
อุทยานแห่งชาติที่เกาะเกาะสุรินทร์มีไม่
ใช่หนึ่งเกาะมี 2 เกาะมีเกาะเล็กๆอีกตรง
นี้เราจะเรียกว่าหมู่เกาะสุรินทร์เพราะ
ว่ามีหลายก่อนเลยเรียกว่าเป็นหมู่เป็นหู
เกาะเกาะสุรินทร์แล้วก็เป็นอุทยานแห่ง
ชาติอุทยานแห่งชาติก็คือฆ่ามีโรงแรมใหญ่ๆ
เอ้าเก็บเก็บไว้เป็นธรรมชาติจริงๆก็เลยจะ
มีห้ามอัดต้นไม้ด้วย
เพราะว่าตาเป็นที่ขอหน้าที่ของประเทศไทย
ประเทศไทยอ่ะไม่ใช่ที่ของใครๆไม่มีใคร
เป็นเจ้าของการขายได้ไหมคะไม่ได้ไม่ได้
เป็นของประเทศไทยครับแม้แต่ก็มีคนอยู่นะ
กูอะตี้ 5 ครับมีคนอยู่บริเวณจะมิ
ตรงนี้เราเรียกว่าชาวมอแกน
ก็ชาวมอแกนเราให้ดูแผนที่ก่อนเนาะชาวมอ
แกนจอ Morgan นี้เป็นคนไทยไหมครับเออเขา
บอกว่า
ตอนนี้เป็นคนไทยขอเป็นคนตายโอเคเอาแล้ว
ทำไมเรียกชาวมอแกนอยู่บ้านมองเป็นชาวชาว
น้ำชาวทะเลคือเขาเป็นอะไรนะเป็นคนที่อยู่
ในเรือมาก่อนเป็นชนเผ่าใช่ไหมครับเป็นชน
เผ่าที่อาศัยอยู่ตามบริเวณชายทะเลโอเค
อยู่ในท่าเรือเลยค่ะอ่ะอ๋ออยู่ในอยู่ใน
เรือไม่สมัยก่อนไม่มีบ้านนะคะอยู่เฉพาะใน
เรือในเรือเท่านั้นและประจุเราเรียกว่า
ชาวน้ำชาวน้ำเนี่ยก็จะมีหลายๆกลุ่มนะคะ
แต่กลุ่มเนี้ยเรียกว่าหมูหม้อแกงกลุ่มนี้
ชื่อ Morgan โอเคถ้าเป็น Morgan แล้วก็
อยู่อยู่ตรงนี้จนตอนนี้มีบ้านละทำเป็น
บ้านอยู่เป็นบ้านนะคะแล้วต้องเข้าก็คือ
เป็นบ้านที่ที่คิคิดถึงธรรมชาติ
วิมานแบบคอนโดหรือตึก 1 ครับอ้าเป็นว่าจะ
พาไปดูนะคะแต่พี่จะบอกนักเรียนเลยคิดว่า
ภาพสมดุลนะไปนะคะตรงเนี้ยแถวนี้
ตรงนี้จุด a จุด B แถวนี้ค่ะจะสามารถว่าย
น้ำแล้วก็
ดำน้ำสีดำน้ำดูประการังได้อ่านดูปลาสวยๆ
ได้ใช่ไหมครับตรงนั้นแต่ว่าถ้ามาตรงนี้
ตรงนี้อุทยานใช่ไหมคะตรงนี้ค่ะอ๋อ
อ้าว
ทำไมถึงห้ามครับตรงนี้ตรงนี้อันตรายใช่
ไหมครับตรงนี้อันตรายมากเพราะว่าตอนนี้
เขาเขาๆช่องขาดน้ำมันจะไหลแล้วนะมาจะ
น้ำเนี่ยน้ำจะไหลจากด้านนี้ไปด้านน้อนเรา
จะเอาคุณออกไปอ๋ออ๋อถ้าใครอยู่ในตรงนั้น
ก็จะไหลออกไปตามน้ำลายอันตรายนะครับคน
ว่ายน้ำแข็งแรงก็อันตรายเขาก็จะบอกว่า
ห้ามเอ่อดูได้จะลงน้ำไม่ได้
ครับแล้วก็ดูโอเคลงน้ำไม่ดี
โอเคเราไปดูกันออกมาเลยไหนขอดูหน่อยสวย
แค่ไหนอันนี้เป็นภาพอ้าว
ตรงนี้นะคะเป็นภาพนานแล้วนะฮะอันนี้เป็น
สุรินทร์เหนืออันนี้สุรินทร์ใต้อ๋อเพื่อ
จะเข้าไปตรงนี้ที่ครู Arty เห็นดำตรง
เนี้ยคือมีความลึกมากกว่า 30 เมตรแสดงว่า
น้ำลึกก็เลยเป็นสีน้ำเงินเข้มนำใช่ไหม
ครับถ้าตรงนี้ก็จะไม่เกิน 10 เมตรนะคะดี
ก็น้ำตื้นหน่อยนะว่ายน้ำได้ใช่ไหมครับ
บริเวณ 50 เมตรไม่น้ำได้ดูประการังดูอะไร
ได้คะกับป้ายนี้ค่ะอันนี้ก็เป็น
อา
ด้านหน้า
ของตรงนี้ค่ะมาเรียนตรงเนี่ยเห็นไหมเห็น
ครับขอมุกเกาะสุรินทร์อ่าน
หมอเขาถ้าเราไปใกล้ๆก็จะเป็นแบบนี้ค่ะ
แล้วก็ถ่ายรูปสวยอ๋อถ้ามีก้อนหินนายอยู่
ต่อที่ชายหาดด้วยโอเคนับทะเลสวยไหมคะสวย
ครับเป็นสีเขียวอ่อนๆจริงๆสวยใช่ไหมกูเอง
มีอะไรจะบอกเวลาน้ำลงลงลงลงลงกว่าที่ลง
ไว้ที่ทะเลตรงนี้มีอะไรเยอะ
มีอะไรมีปะการังเหรอครับหรือมีโคลนไม่ใช่
นี่มีอีกตัวสีดำๆ
ปลิงทะเลเหรอครับใช่
อ๋ออ้าวแถวนี้มีคนมาว่ายน้ำไหมครับ R
ปกติเข้าใจเดินชายหาดแล้วว่ายน้ำนิดหน่อย
นะคะคนไปที่น่าจะไปดํานํ้าจะดำน้ำบริเวณ
ที่ที่ไกลก็ใช้ห่ารหัสไก่ตรงที่ไม่มีปลิง
ทะเลในครัวที่เคยได้ยินว่าปลิงทะเลกินได้
ใช่ไหมครับสีดำกินไม่ได้สีขาวสีเทากินได้
อือที่อาจจะไม่ได้อยู่ตรงนี้เลยอาจจะอยู่
ตรงนี้ค่ะประมาณตรงนี้อ่ะ
ประมาณซักขนาดประมาณประมาณเอวขึ้นมาค่ะ
ประมาณสูงประมาณเอวก็มาทำไมคุยรู้ไหมทำไม
ใหม่ตอนน้ำลงอ๋ออ๋อก็มองเห็นใช่ไหมใช่น้ำ
ลงเนี่ยเรือเข้าไม่ได้ราคาเรือเข้าไม่ได้
เราก็ต้องเดินขอ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ก็
คือเมื่อก่อนครูเอ๋ทำงานที่ทะเลเนาะเวลา
ลงเนี่ยแต่กูเองไปไม่กี่ครั้งหรอกถ้าน้ำ
ลงปุ๊บเนี่ยก็ต้องมีเราไปทำงานแล้วก็ต้อง
ไปเอาติงทะเลออกก่อนหรอเชิญค่ะ Turn ออก
นะคะเวลาคนไปเที่ยวมาก็เดินตรงที่ไม่มี
ปลิงทะเลอ๋อ
มันกดรู้คนชอบก็ชอบนะเราไม่อายเขาตายอ้ะ
ตื่นเต้นดีจะได้ครับแต่อย่าไปเหยียบมัน
อยากไปเดินเหยียบลิงเลใจครับอ่ะแล้วก็
ตรงนี้ก็จะเป็นอุทยานแห่งชาตินะคะเป็น
บ้านพักในอุทยานค่ะ
เดี๋ยวนี้มีบ้านพักถ้าจองไปอ่ะค่ะก็นอน
ได้
แต่ว่าไม่ไม่มีไม่มีโรงแรมใหญ่ๆอะไรไม่มี
มีแต่บ้านพักอุทยานนะ / แล้ว
และอีกฝั่งนึงนี่แหละค่ะ
ชาวๆน้ำชาวทะเล Morgan ใช่มั้ย
เดี๋ยวนี้มีหมู่บ้านหมู่บ้านมอแกนเป็น
บ้านนะคะใช่มีบ้านหลายหลังเลยทรายทำไมกู
เอกไปอ่ะมีบ้านแค่นิดหน่อยแต่ว่าเขาจะ
อยู่ในเรือกูเอกไปคือประมาณ 30  29 ขอ
อายุ 19
5  30 กว่าปีที่แล้วนั้น
ก็ไม่มีบ้านแบบนี้แต่ว่าจะมีบ้านนิดหน่อย
แล้วเขาก็จะอยู่ในทะเลนะคะแต่กกฏเขกค่อย
คุยกับคน Morgan นะถามว่าอายุเท่าไหร่
เขาบอกว่า 36
36 ปีอ้าวมีแฟนหน้าเนี่ยน่าจะ
50  60 ออก
ทำไมครับเพราะว่าเขาตากแดดเยอะใช่ไหม
เค้านับเขานับตามคลื่นน่ะอายุตามคืน
คลื่นมา 1 ครั้ง 1 ปี
คลื่นใหญ่ๆค่ะอ๋อ
เขาบอกว่าคลื่นใหญ่น่ะจะมา 1 ปีปีอ่ากับ
เขาก็เลยนับตามคลื่นถ้าคืนไม่มาก็ยังไม่
มีอายุนี่
[เพลง]
สมัยโบราณนะสมัยโบราณจะปัจจุบันน่ะเขา
เปลี่ยนแล้วนะคะมีมีปฏิทินมีเช็คว่าปี
อะไรนะคะซึ่งสายกูเป็นๆเนาะ
ดีค่ะก็เป็นหมู่บ้านมอแกนไปเที่ยวได้
คนในหมู่บ้านมอแกนเนี่ย Arty ครับบ้าน
หมู่บ้านเป็นแบบเนี้ยกูจะตีเห็นหมาบ้านทำ
จากอ่าอ่าต้นไม้อะไรครับมายคุณย่าต้นไม้
อ๋อเคเป็นใบใบหญ้าใบจากกลับมาหาแล้วก็พูด
เรือเรือเดี๋ยวนี้มีอันนี้ตกใจมีเรือหาง
ยาวเนี่ย
สมัยก่อนเดินเรือพาย
โรคเปลี่ยนไปแล้วนะเจ้าพาแล้วก็เรือลำ
ใหญ่ขึ้นด้วยแสดงว่าเป็นเรือนัดท่อง
เที่ยวชาย
เขาอะรับนักท่องเที่ยวเข้าไปเป็นน่าจะ
เป็นออกแบบโครง Stay อ่ะอยู่กับชาวมอแกน
ไปเลยรับอันนี้ก็เป็นรูปที่เอามาให้ดูนะ
คะเป็นชาวมอแกนก็จะใส่ผ้าถุงแบบนี้เรา
เรียกว่ากระโจมอก
อาบเดี๋ยวนี้มีเสื้อผ้าใส่นะคะสมัยก่อนก็
จะก็ใส่กางเกงข้างบนใส่บ้างไม่ใส่บ้างนะ
คะ
ตอนนี้ก็มีพัฒนาขึ้นอาบแล้วก็นี่ค่ะเป็น
เด็กๆมอบแกน
ดำน้ำจับจับปลาเหงื่อ
นี่เป็นรูปรูปสมัยโบราณนะคะลูกเก่าสมัย
รูปเก่าปัจจุบันเด็กเด็กหน้าจัดโปรหมด
แล้ว
พูดภาษาไทยได้ภาษาอังกฤษได้เก่งหมดแล้วนะ
ๆ
นากาที่นี้มาดูใต้ทะเลของ
ของขอบสุรินทร์บ้านหน้ามีปลาด้วยใช่ไหม
ครับ 5 มีป้าสวยๆเยอะเลยใช่ไหมครับมายค่ะ
กลุ่มนี้ก็เป็นปลาปลาสินสมุทรพ่อเป็นปลา
ทะเลปลาสินหมดกวนตีลูฟี่ปลาพรุ่งนี้เนื้อ
หารูปยากนะ
ครับได้ไม่ไม่ค่อยเจอแต่เจอที่หนูเกาะ
สุรินทร์ขอพูดเวลาเจอเราจะดีจะหาตื่นเต้น
มากนะครับเพราะว่าไม่เคยเจอที่อื่นอ่ะพบ
ภูเก็ตก็ไม่เห็นนะโอเคในเอาคอหรือยังไมํ
มีนะคะแต่ว่าถ้าเกิดในทะเลหลายๆที่ไม่มี
หัวหินพัทยาหรือทางฝั่งเกาะช้างก็ไม่มี
ค่ะก็จะมีที่นี่เท่านั้นเราก็มีปลาแบบนี้
ค่ะนี่คือแถวหมู่เกาะสุรินทร์เลยสวยคืน
ถ้าขวดดีชอบชอบดูปลาค่ะต้องไปเอาที่หนูก็
กินข้าวชอบลานะคะหมู่เกาะสุรินทร์หมู่
เกาะสิมิลันซึ่งจะอยู่ที่พังงาเหมือนกัน
ครับ
ชอบดำน้ำไหมคะเอ่อชอบนิดหน่อยครับพี่ก็
ยังไม่เคยใช่มั้ยอ๋อเคยไปดํานํ้าบ้างแต่
ว่าไม่ได้ดำน้ำลึกที่หมู่เกาะสุรินทร์ใน
ยังไม่เคยไปอันนี้กู Arty ไม่ต้องดำน้ำ
ลึกค่ะเอาเป็นอ่าดำสมัครอร์นสกินนักเสนอ
ได้ใช่ไหมครับ
ดำผิวน้ำเพราะว่าประมาณ 5 ถึง 10 เมตรนี่
คือน้ำใส่มากอ๋อครับถ้าอีกหมู่เกาะนึงอ้ะ
15 ม 10 เมตร 15 เมตรน้ำก็ใสสามารถมอง
เห็นแบบนี้เลย
โอเคใสสะอาดมากนะคะแล้วก็จะเห็นแบบนี้
เยอะหอยมือเสือหอยมือเสือตัวนี้เลยตัวนี้
เรียกว่าหอยมือเสือนะคะตัวใหญ่มากสมัย
ก่อนนะครู Arty เอา Morgan อ่ะเขาก็จะ
เก็บหอยมือเสือก็น่ะมันกินเนาะขอกินได้
ใช่ไหมครับกินได้เขากินนะไม่ใช่เราหนัง
เอ็กเต็มไม่เป็นว่าตัวมันใหญ่มากอ้ะหอย
มือเสือตัวใหญ่จะสีสวยตอนนี้เขาไม่ให้กิน
แล้วมาให้ข้าก็
ก๊อปซื้ออาหารกินอ่อนซื้อไก่ซื้อหมูกับ
ปลายังกินได้อยู่ปลาสวยงามกินไม่ได้นะคะ
เป็นปลาที่เป็นอาหาร
อันนี้ชาวมอแกนก็เลยขายเสื้อขอไม่จับหอย
ขายแล้วขายเสื้อแทนน้อโอเคมีขายเสื้อมี
อะไรนะมีรับนักท่องเที่ยวนะคะแบบนั้นอ๋อ
เรายังมีเวลาไหมคะกู Arty ยังมีเวลาอยู่
อีก 6 นาที
6 นาทีเราไปสิมิลันนิดหน่อยได้มั้ยน่า
ได้ครับได้ครับตัวที่คิดว่านักเรียนหลายๆ
คนก็น่าจะรู้จักสิมิลันชายก็กรีดหมู่เกาะ
สุรินทร์จะอยู่ด้านบนและสิมิลันจะอยู่
ข้างล่างอ่ะ
เกาะสิมิลันจะอยู่ล่างโลมาที่ใกล้กับ
ภูเก็ตหน่อยหนึ่ง
นี่หมู่เกาะสิมิลัน
มา
อะตี้เคยไปใช่ไหมใต้เคยไปสิมิลันค่ะคู่
เอกเคยไปก็คือไปกอดนี้น้องอะนี้แล้วก็กด
นี้อ่ะสองเกาะนะคะสองเกาะอื่นๆกูเองยัง
ไม่เสร็จไปไปแค่ 2 เกาะเขามาเกาะใหญ่ๆของ
สิเป็นอันจะมี 9 เกาะนะคะ
อาซื้ออันนี้ค่ะคุยไปเกาะไหนเนี่ยออกเกาะ
สี่เกาะ
สีอะไรไปดูเกาะ 4 ก่อนคือจะมีชื่อก่อนนะ
เพราะกรอบ 8 กับเกาะสี่อันนี้เกาะ 4 อ่ะ
อ่ะตรงนี้อา
เรียกว่าอ้าเป็นสันแม่ของเธอจิมิลันเลย
ครับวันนี้เป็นหินหินมีชื่อด้วยอันนี้
เป็นหินหินใบพัดใช่ไหมอ่ะเขาเห็นเนี่ย
เขียนใบพัดเรือ
โอเค
ครับคุณแม่เขียนเรือใบก็เลยงง
อากินมั้ยพัดเรือตรงนี้กู Arty
เคยไปใช่ไหมคะที่สิมิลันจ่ายทรายเคยไปนะ
กูอะติ๊กขึ้นไปตรงนี้ไหมคะอ้าวันนั้นที่
กลัวตีไปกว่าตีไม่ได้ขึ้นไปครับเพราะว่า
ฝนตกแล้วเขาบอกว่ามันอันตรายมันจะลืนๆเขา
ก็เลยบอกว่าไม่ไม่แนะนำให้ขึ้นไปแต่ถ้าจะ
ขึ้นไปก็ได้แต่ตัวแต่ไม่ได้ขึ้นไปเพราะ
ว่าพาลูกไปด้วยลูกตอนนั้นลูกก็ยังเล็ก
อยู่ก็เลยไม่ได้ขึ้นไปจะตอนนี้ลูกโตนะวัน
นี้โอนแล้วครับ
ว่าทางเดินขึ้นลำบากนั้นอ่ะกูอ่ะเหรอกับ
พี่ดูแบบนี้สวยใช่ไหมคะแต่คุณจะเอาทางนี้
ค่ะแล้วมันจะต้องอ้อมก้อนหินเป็นแบบเนี้ย
เราจะจะต้องเกาะเชือกไปอาบเดี๋ยวต้องมีคน
คอยล็อคว่าอะขึ้นไปนะอย่าออกมานอกเชื่อ
เพราะว่าเชือกดีก็จะแบบทำให้น้องเกาะขึ้น
ไปได้ 5 แล้วก็พออยู่ข้างบนน่ะถ่ายรูปออก
มาก็จะเป็นแบบนี้ก็เห็นชย
ตายห่าก็ทั้งหมู่เกาะสุรินทร์แล้วก็หมู่
เกาะสิมิลันอ้ะเหมาะสำหรับคนที่ชอบดูปลา
เพราะว่าปลาสวยๆเยอะนะครับแล้วชายหาดที่
นี่นะกู Arty ว่าที่กูอาทิตย์ไปกว่าที่
ว่าสวยไหมสวย
ทรายเป็นยังไงคะได้ตายก็เป็นทรายละเอียด
สีขาวสวยสวยละเอียดมากฮัลโหลนุ่มหนุ่มหา
ทรายน้ำตรงเนี้ย Arty  Oh ขอกู้เอกขึ้น
เคยเคยคิดว่าตื่นตื่นๆ
ลงมาที่นี่อะแล้วไว้นะไม่เก่งแล้วตอนนั้น
ทุกวันนี้ก็ไม่เจ๋งก็มีรุ่นพี่บ่เฮ็ดน้ำ
ตื้นลงกระโดดอุ้ยมันลง
ขอโทษนะเช้าไม่ถึงพื้น
อ่อนลึกไม่ได้ครับอ่าน 10 เมตร
ตกใจแต่ว่าไม่เป็นไรค่ะน้ำทะเลเขาจะดำเรา
ขึ้นมาก็น้องก็เต้นดันขึ้นมาอาหารซูชิ
ใจว่าน้ำใสใช่ไหมครับก็เลยคิดว่าอ้อไม่
ลึกหรอกเพราะว่ามันมองเห็นข้างล่างใช่ไหม
ไม่คิดว่าน้ำไม่ลึกแต่นางจริงแล้วน้ำลึก
น้ำใสมากนำลึกนะคะลึกมากนะคะตรงนี้
สนุกค่ะคนที่ปิดไปว่ายน้ำแถวนี้ไหมคะๆ
ว่ายน้ำอยู่แถวนั้นล่ะครับแล้วออกมาแถว
นี้มั้ยมาดูหน้าตาเจ้านี่อ่าข้างนอกเป็น
ออกไปขอสมเด็จแสดงว่าอยู่แถวนี้ตายๆว่าย
น้ำเล่นอยู่แถวข้างนอกพรุ่งนี้จะได้
โอกาสหน้านะกู Arty เอาต้องดำน้ำถ้าไป
หมู่เกาะสุรินทร์หมู่เกาะสิมิลันต้องดำ
น้ำดำน้ำๆไม่ชอบจริงๆบางคนไม่ชอบเอาอะไร
ใส่ปากขอก็ตีได้ดำน้ำได้แต่วันนั้นวันที่
ควรปีไปกว่านั้นน่ะฝนตกเอาก็เลยบอกว่าไม่
แนะนำให้ดำน้ำเพราะมันจะมีคลื่นแรงเลย
เนี่ยมันอันตราย
ไงก็เลยไม่ได้ดำน้ำได้เสียดายไว้ไว้ไป
ใหม่นะคะ
ก็ ami อีกนิดหน่อยนะครับอันนี้ก็อันนี้
ก็จะเป็นเกาะที่ 8 นะคะตอบ 8 โอเคกูเอกก็
จะไปตรงนี้ประจำแล้วคู่เอกก็ไม่รู้ว่ามี
อุทยานแห่งชาติ
อา
เกาะ 4 กับ 4  4 มันจะกลับ 8 เมื่อกี้ไป
เกาะแปดอันนี้เกาะสี
อันไหนเกาะสีอะไรก็นี้ก่อน 4 ใช่ไหมในก็
เขียนไว้เกาะเมี่ยงเกาะ 4  4
นะไม่เห็นคุยดูก่อนว่าใช่ๆเกาะแปดเมื่อ
กี้เราไปเกาะ 8 ไม่ใช่เกาะ 4 นะคะแอบเค
เราก็เกาะสี่ก็คือเกาะอยู่หน้าร้านตรงนี้
เกาะ 4 ที่มีอุทยาน
นายประ 4 จะอยู่ตรงนี้นะคะเกาะเมี่ยง
เมี่ยงก็จะมีอุทยาน
ขอโทษค่ะทรายคุยวงไว้แล้วนั้นเกาะเมี่ยง
นี่นะคะอันนี้จะมีอุทยานแห่งชาติ
แต่ครูเอกไปทีไรอยู่มุมนี้ไม่เคยเห็น
อุทยานแห่งชาติเคยเห็นครั้งเดียว
อยู่คนละด้านกันใช่ไหมอยู่คนละทานของเกาะ
ก็ต้องเดินทะลุหาทะลุป่าตรงเนี้ยต้องเดิน
จากตรงเนี้ยเขาไปก็จะเป็นอีกชายฝั่งหนึ่ง
อาบว่าจะเห็นอุทยานสวยนะคะด้านอุทยานอ่ะ
แล้วก็
จุดเด่นของเกาะนี้ก็คือตอนกลางคืนนะค่ะจะ
ได้ยินเสียงไก่
จะรู้ที่กูเอกให้ดูไม่ใช่ลูกไก่นะครับใช่
ถ้าไม่ใช่ไก่ไปเสียงปูตัวนี้ค่ะอ๋อเป็นปู
ที่กูที่ร้องเสียงเหมือนไก่เหรอครับได้
คือไม่รู้เขาส่งเสียงอะไรออกมาแล้วสิมัน
มีอวัยวะส่วนหนึ่งของเขาอ่ะอ๋อ
ลมผ่านออกมาแล้วกลายเป็นเสียงมันเสียงใจ
อ่อนเงินกูกุ๊กเหมือนไก่บางคนเขาก็เลยไป
ดูนะคะเป็น
ไปดูก็ไม่เจอไก่เจอแต่ปู
ไม่รู้ปู
ฮะ
โอเค
จริงๆแล้วเนี่ยนักเรียนช้าแถวยังมีอีก
เกาะอื่นๆอีกนะคะที่จังหวัดพังงาอย่าง
เช่นเกาะนี้ชื่อว่าเกาะปันหยีก็น่าเที่ยว
นะคะ
ก็เป็นอีกอ้อก็มีมีเป็นหมู่บ้านเป็นหมู่
บ้านมุสลิมอยู่ในน้ำเลยอ่ะแล้วตรงนี้ก็
เป็นป่า
ให้ครับมีปลาอยู่ไทยเลนบัญชีเรือก็ลองไป
ดูดูต้นไม้รหัส
เวลาหมดแล้วใช่ไหมคะใส่ครับเวลาหมดแล้ว
ครับหมดแล้วเดี๋ยวเขาหน้าถ้ามีโอกาส
เดี๋ยวพาไปเที่ยวที่อื่นในจังหวัดพังงา
ต่อเพราะว่าจังหวัดพังงาเนี่ยมีกรอบมี
ทะเลสวยๆเยอะมากมากนักเรียนเกาะเยอะเอา
ง่ายๆว่าถ้านักเรียนจะไปเที่ยวพังงาเนี่ย
5 วันไม่ไม่พออ๋อ
ถ้าเที่ยวทั้งหมดนะตัวเองว่า 5 วันไม่พอ
ครับแต่ถ้าไปโอเคหมู่เกาะสุรินทร์ป่ะอาจ
จะ 3 วัน 5 วันพอแต่ถ้าไปทุกที่เนี่ยน่า
จะไม่พอน่ะไม่พอครับโอเคค่ะคืนนี้ก็พานัก
เรียนไปเที่ยวจังหวัดพังงาหมก I  done นะ
คะ
หมดเวลาแล้วนะครับเดี๋ยวกลัวตี้กับกูเอก
ต้องลาไปก่อนนะครับเดี๋ยวกลับมาเจอกัน
ใหม่ในคลิปหน้าครับถ้าลาไปก่อนครับสวัสดี
ครับบ๊ายบายครับพี่เอ๋บ๊ายบายน